welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker on this
episode I talk with Connor Leahy Connor
is the CEO of conjecture which is an
organization dedicated to scalable AI
alignment
this episode is a lightning round I ask
Connor a lot of questions about a lot of
different topics and so you get to hear
Connor's opinions about everything
ranging from Aliens to economics to
mimetics
to education everything it's a super
interesting episode I hope you enjoy it
here is Connor Leahy
great and we're back honor welcome back
glad to be back I'm gonna do something
I'm gonna give you an impossible task
which is to answer complex questions
quickly oh [__] yes and I I call this
the semi lightning round or a pseudo
lightning round because I want you to
actually uh you know actually explain
your answer a bit so I don't want you to
give me a 30 second answer but it'll
take us uh let's see if we can move a
little faster here and get your takes on
a lot of different topics
um you're for this
yeah let's go okay perfect are there
aliens in the universe depends on what
you mean by universe
[Music]
sorry I'm terrible at this damn it
in the observable universe maybe
probably ish
yeah dude
didn't say anything about your thinking
on this topic
look up grabby aliens like I mean it's
something I kind of defer my opinion
there to like that one fhi like you know
20 the universe is empty thing plus
crabby alien kind of anthropic-ish
models I don't think about too much UFOs
are definitely not aliens though so
anyone who thinks those are aliens like
obviously not they're obviously are
simulators messing with us
will humans ever upload our own minds
I mean if we survive the uh you know
takeoff yeah
the AI take off you mean yep yeah okay
so um what motivates you to work on AI
safety yeah is the world is nice there's
a lot of nice things things could be
even nicer a lot of people they you know
I like them to be happy I don't like
suffering I'd like to prevent suffering
it's a little thing to do
do you find that your motivation is
affected by your uh perhaps pessimism
about the difficulty of the problem are
you are you more motivated the harder
the problem is or is there is there you
know could the problem be so hard that
you would simply give up or be not
motivated if a problem isn't possible
it's not particularly motivating to work
on but as I said before it's It's
Curious that we live in a timeline where
we're not obviously lost we're like the
odds are extremely against us it's like
but we haven't lost it it's this is the
thing actually that um people ask me
sometimes is they're like counter why
you have these like terrible pessimistic
timelines but you don't seem to be
depressed and I'm really not like at all
I'm like super happy all the time like
lately in particular like ever since
I've really started like really working
on this problem as the happiest I've
ever been in my life and I'm like it's
like
it's like I don't know to be a bit you
know poetic or whatever it's like you
know some people are built for the
valley some people are built for the
mountains and I feel like I'm built for
the mountains is like I kind of like my
whole life I feel like I've just been
like waiting for something to do like
I'm just like oh oh war is finally here
all right let's go like I'm ready let's
let's do this
do you think it has something to do with
the alignment of your values with your
actions so is is that a fundamental of
of human happiness in in your case I
think it is yes like this is something
that's like always been like
even so I'm like you know I always try
to be a big brain Russian list like
thinking about consequentialists and
whatever like at heart I've always been
very virtue ethicist and now I've like
come back around towards like virtue
ethics and such being actually a good
and consequentialism bad in many ways
and
like I have a deep deep aesthetic
reappreciation for like heroism as a
concept and like honor and like you know
sacrifice Mercy like it's all like very
if you know things that in our modern
world kind of are you know trite you
know or like you know they feel like
kind of cutesy but like I have a felt
sense like there's a felt sense in my
mind of like honor and heroism it's like
fundamental into logical Concepts that
are like valuable and like feel very
good like this is
um it feels like in a sense that my felt
sense I'm not like describing any kind
of like like moral reality to any of
this to be clear this is just a felt
aesthetic sense like felt aesthetic
sense of like heroism as like a
fundamental concept of goodness and like
a fundamental thing that I and like
sacrifice you know I know very classic
Western very classic like you know or
like even Christian or like you know
heroic Aesthetics but
um I don't know it's just always been
how I've been like you know as a kid I
was like you know when I was like you
know it was like very quite young I
would like I had this I had sleeping
issues when I was a kid I I had terrible
insomnia I would it take me like three
hours to fall asleep every single night
and
it wasn't bad though as a kid I was like
great it's thinking time it's just like
sit alone no one will bother me I can
just think of stories and like think
about philosophy and Science and just
like you do that and then I would look
for hours and hours and hours and hours
and hours and hours and hours I would
just think about what does it mean to be
a hero and like that was like this like
it's very funny because like for me it
was like the like fundamental concept it
was like a mystery I had to solve it was
like it was as real to me as physics it
was like something where it's like
surely there's a true definition I just
haven't found it what does you know
classic like you know you know pre-post
modern philosophy kind of like thinking
of like you're finding the true
definition of goodness during the
Socrates thing of
examining a concept from all angles
until you find the true definition which
it's it's in some sense a Fool's learned
but perhaps you learn something in the
in the process exactly so like I I'm I'm
like obviously like obviously these are
just like you know contingent Concepts
and obviously it's just like my own like
you know surf aesthetic sense like I
don't to strive like reality to any of
these Concepts or like you know
universality to any of these ideas but
so I went through the phase of like you
know as a kid being like taking these
things super seriously then you know
like an older teen I was you know it
become edgy atheist you know moral
realists you know uh not sorry like more
relativists or like whatever but then I
kind of like came back around where I'm
like yeah I I'm not like saying these
are like universally compelling or
whatever but they mean a lot to me and
so screw you I can do whatever I want
you know I'd be more uh it's easier to
see how the virtues would apply to your
daily life than it is to see how uh the
moral theory of consequentialism would
apply it's it's it it very often or very
easily gets uh incredibly complex and
meta with consequentialism whereas
virtue thinking in terms of virtue is is
something that you can apply
um more easily I would think virtue is
the ethics for humans consequentialism
is the ethics for gods
okay on the topic of consequentialism is
infinity a problem there so is infinity
a problem for the moral theory of
consequentialism yes absolutely uh
infinity is a con is a problem for
almost everything actually I have a
stupid spicy opinions about infinity and
philosophy and how people are very very
confused about what Infinity is
especially that people don't understand
that there are embedded creatures living
in an embedded reality and you can like
very easily derived paradoxes from
Infinities especially higher order
Infinities I like begrudgingly accept
you know like the you know aleph null
Infinity but I'm like
I'm like you know I'm you know jokingly
um you know morally against higher order
Infinities because I think they it's
like all these kind of weird paradoxes
that people like real numbers are
obviously not real like anyone who says
real numbers is real you're on my
naughty list like I'm gonna fight you
do you think there are actual kind of um
real world implications of thinking
about in Infinity does it change uh
anything about what we should do
yep absolutely I think people are very
confused about many things I for example
expect that black holes are not
infinitely dense that this is just a
confusion that's because we're confused
about what Infinity means and what you
know how time works and like analogs and
stuff and that if we had a more uh a
different kind of theory for example
based on like intuitionistic logic or
like you know some other kind of like
computable logic then we would find that
actually black holes have very different
properties I expect this to be the case
for ethics and such like like
the classic example is or like you know
infinite ethics where it's like well if
you believe in like infinite multiverses
or whatever well then you should assign
zero value this universe because it's
you know a zero size slice of infinity
so therefore you should have no interest
whatsoever and anything that happens in
this reality and you should only care
about you know affecting like you know
hyper Computing Multiverse or whatever
this is the kind of thing where if you
encounter this kind of thought your
immediate reaction should be
no like just say no just turn around
just go back home like obviously this is
insane like the so the funny thing about
like alien Gods from Beyond reality you
know these like hyper intelligence super
touring you know machines from Beyond
reality that you know it can't you know
come in through infinite mathematics is
they can all be defeated by simply
saying no you can defeat roku's basilisk
by just saying no and then it's gone
that's it that's all you needed to do
you're thinking you can you can defeat
all this very abstract philosophy and
Mathematics by simply trying to be
heroic or insisting that you that you
act virtuous you don't even need that
just say no that sounds stupid just go
home like like someone gives you some
Galaxy brain [__] roku's basilist
argument oh well you see now that you
know about the basically it will harm
you I'm like no I don't believe in the
Basilisk and now the Basilisk can't
torture you because it has no causal
influence it causes influence over you
because you don't believe in it
so like even by the Basilisk standard of
what it is it doesn't work you literally
just have to say nah that sounds like
[__] and then you're free and like I
think there's a lot of like Galaxy
braining that happens in like infinite
ethics in particular where people say
like we'll assume we observed a hyper
turing machine I'm like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
it's three steps back you cannot observe
a hyper turing machine it would take
infinite steps to verify whether a
system is a hypertory machine or not not
just like arbitrary mini infinite
humans can't do infinite steps so any
conclusion that follows in your later
you know 50 000 word essay I can dismiss
out of hand I don't need to read it it's
already wrong you already made a mistake
so there's so you can reason about
higher order things like this if you
want but you have but people get
confused about what they're actually
reasoning about
they use symbols so this is the classic
like humans get confusing themselves
with symbols you know is like you have a
symbol and we'll call this you know
infinite you know steps or whatever
right and you can like say things about
the symbol you know there's like all
kinds of things you can do with this
symbol you can do all kinds of algebraz
on this emblem whatever and that's all
cute
but it's not Infinity
you can't interact with infinity in
Infinity is infinitely big there is no
thing you can you can't touch it it's
not something that will ever affect
anything that only affects you after
infinite steps does not affect you
because you will never exist for
infinite steps this is actually my
criticism where I mentioned you know a
while back but I see and like islaminoff
induction so to quickly explain the
point the problem with with IC and like
so it's like IC is provably the most
intelligent agent you can get is that it
will always converge to the best
solution possible
given up to a constant so this is
actually crazy this is actually a crazy
result like when you first read you're
like what like this is why no matter
what's there you put this thing in right
it will always get to the correct
solution
as fast as fast as possible up to a
constant wow that's that's crazy that's
like when I first read this result I was
like wow that's not what I expected
that's pretty impressive
but then you notice there's a [__]
trick like yeah oh wait I've been
deceived there is a trick here that
constant is arbitrarily large it can be
anything that constant can be any number
it can it doesn't matter
it can be
you know Graham's numbers times the size
of your Universe like it doesn't matter
it can be anything so it can actually be
implemented in our universe yeah I mean
we can't even implement it because you
also need to have like halting oracles
to make implement this but even if you
could it still wouldn't work like I mean
well well the approximations would work
so if you try to uh so basically the the
the the cheesy way of saying it is IC
can be arbitrarily wrong about arbitrary
facts for arbitrarily long
yeah uh okay if you could have a long
conversation with anyone who would you
have this conversation with
live Dead or Alive oh that's a great
question
um
can can I change their influence or is
this just gaining information
we I can't give you the the physics of
time travel here it's uh okay there's a
distracting information yeah it's just
extracting information
I mean
assuming no one from the future I mean I
guess it would I've talked to most
really smart people alive today so maybe
like Von Newman or Einstein
um maybe someone like that uh well
actually I mean
if I was munchkining this if I was Min
maxing this I would find someone who has
a very relevant piece of historical
information that I could like abuse to
like exploit the market or something
um but I would have to think more about
that I would probably be interested in
talking to yeah maybe Von Newman or
someone like that but or I mean if I
wasn't trying to min max I was just
curious I would
probably greatly enjoy talking to
leipknitz
um I think liveness is a very
interesting character I consider
likeness to be the first alignment
researcher
um there's a great set of like book
length essays about like the history of
computability and logic
um Forgot by who unfortunately and the
first one a lot of is about leibniz so
it's this is very funny he when
leipeness first put his
um doctoral thesis his uh he he applied
for doctoral thesis and his application
was that he would create the uni the the
you know natural language of Philosophy
by which you know the will of God and
everything could be formalized so in the
future when two philosophers disagree
they must they need merely say let us
compute you want to formalize all things
in just one universal language which is
if it's like like you know 1600s or like
1700s or whatever and like based like
awesome like what a guy like this guy is
like inventing like the idea of formal
logic and like the idea of like
formalizing the will of God you know
into formal logic so it can be
implemented on Earth I'm like man yeah
this guy's the first alignment
researcher I love it imagine being
leibnized back then and then trying to
differentiate differentiate between your
ideas that are crazy and your ideas that
are brilliant and it must be so so
difficult because he also has published
some
far out views about ontology but oh yeah
obviously but it's like same thing like
Newton like Newton considered his
physics Works to not be his greatest
works he thought like his like alchemic
illness like biblical interpretation
work to be like this is another thing
about epistemology where like people
have very confused views about like how
it was to be a pre-scientific person and
like how different it actually was we
have like movies like you know people go
back in time where we see like
historical people and they're like kind
of like us you know they don't know
certain facts you know but they're like
they reason about things much more than
we do like people don't understand that
like people even like a hundred years
ago or whatever we're [__] Savages
like compared to today they were Savage
they were awful like the violence and
the abuse and the like the drunkenness
one of my I I have to this is completely
irrelevant but I I have to do your your
listeners a favor here
um if you want to look up something just
to truly
truly awaken you to like how weird
history is you have to look up the
Lester balloon riots so this is one of
my favorite little anecdotes of History
I I Stumble those by complete acts so
okay
balloon riots well that's kind of weird
right like okay so I want you to imagine
your head what happened here okay maybe
there was some Riot for some reason that
involved balloons for some reason or
became like a symbol of balloon
something nope wasn't that all right so
uh okay let's have like like 1800s or
something so like something like hot air
balloons maybe someone was using them
for some like bad purpose or something
no no it's much better than that so what
happened was
this true look at it on Wikipedia
um was that
um some noble man had built a hot air
balloon and whatever and so he was
trying to you know
um go up into the air balloon and just
like look at things so a huge crowd of
like spectators
uh came to look at to watch and what
happened was that a riot broke out
people got
you know went you know insane basically
and like pour the balloon apart and
burnt it so like Eddie like yeah I had
like run away and so
why okay so I want you to imagine your
mind what could have caused this the
reasoning was and I quote that they had
heard it wasn't the biggest balloon
they were just like what oh this is the
best one [__] this guy kill him like
that's actually what happened like
people just like they were so drunk and
just so [__] up that it was like get
them boys [__] this balloon and
apparently this was such a big problem
that during that time it was a regular
occurrence that people would try to hide
when they had their balloon takeoffs to
not attract too large of crowds because
like [__] like this would just keep
[__] happening this is this was
definitely not my guess I would have
guessed something that perhaps they saw
the balloon is a God and and were scared
by it or something yeah no no no they
were just like like they were just like
someone you know I think it's like I can
actually imagine what happened like
after I thought about it for like when I
first heard this I'm like this is absurd
how the [__] is that but then I thought
about it some more and I remember when
like you know me and the boys were like
young when we're like 18 or 17 and we
would get like really drunk and then I'm
like oh I can see how this happens like
I actually drunk that there's an
interesting uh semi-serious uh theory
about drunkenness which is that uh there
was a before 1700 there were there were
a lot of pups in in London and the UK in
general
and
um people were drunk uh people were off
the work they got out they went out and
they drank a lot and then they fell
asleep and then they never really
achieved anything intellectually but
with the introduction of coffee houses
people had a different stimulant or had
a stimulant effect as opposed to a kind
of a downer effect from the alcohol and
then they began intellectualizing and
talking and the developing theories and
so on that's it my I don't know how
seriously to take this but the point is
just to say drunkenness was a was a huge
problem in the past and I I think you're
right that it's we we we can't really
understand how how the world was back
then yeah it's crazy it's like like
people were like whenever you read the
history book you have to remember all
these people who are just like pissed
strong all the time everyone was drunk
all the time you couldn't drink water
right water was it could be potentially
poisonous and yeah
but it was very common for just everyone
to be drunk all the time and you know
illiterate and like violent and like
like I remember reading I think it was
in better angels of our nature where you
just talked about how like in the
medieval world like everyone had a knife
with them a couple of times like this
was just you know because you know you
need nice for all kinds of things so
people just stab each other at dinner
all the time like people just get
murdered at dinner all the time and this
is just normal it's again you know it's
like oh man you know old farmer Bob
that bread yeah as I mean I mean death
would be much more common and you would
you would expect to encounter death from
uh disease or from violence uh much more
often than we do we we are absolutely
shocked if we encounter death but let's
um so what will be the most impressive
thing that the gpt4 will be able to do
no I'm using up all my trading Alpha no
um I don't know what the most impressive
thing would be because I expect once
people have it in their hands they're
gonna like you know elicit more and more
impressive things I expect really good
side is going to make it do some pretty
amazing things pretty quickly
um
one of the things I know it can do is
that it's going to be able to write much
more sophisticated software than like
the current systems can do like chat GPT
is like great for like Snippets and
stuff but I can't write whole programs
before write whole programs
that's that is actually that that could
change things substantially yep
what uh what do you think how do you
think the internet has affected our
ability to think do you think it's been
uh negative positive in which ways has
it been negative and positive
I think it is the
average is positive the mean is negative
so well actually I'm not even sure if
that's true it might even be positive on
the mean so like again people don't
realize how Savage the past was it's
like there's always been the question of
like you know has the internet made us
Dumber or made our stupidity more
accessible I think it's actually mostly
the second well I think on average the
internet has made people much smarter
it's made people more skeptical it's
made people more capable of like
thinking we're exposed to different
viewpoints and whatever but what it has
also made us
ex is that it exposes us to Super memes
to Super infectious like super dangerous
memes I think of like um me exposed to
the internet is kind of like being like
a tropical disease researcher you're
probably going to have a really good
immune system but you also are exposed
to like the worst things and like you
know like hyper you know contagious like
dangerous things
so what I I think those results on on
net is that Society kind of stratifies
more we have more Tales we have more
hyper rational people like I think the
most rational people to ever live are
currently alive
like I I like even if you read like you
know very rational people or like very
smart people like Einstein or Von Newman
if you actually read the biographies
carefully like
a bit Savage you know like by modern day
standards still you know and not just
racism and stuff but like also that
just like have more like you know uh
sophisticated we are in like many of
these like
regards they're like the average person
of today
at least you know like things that
rationality should be important or
science should be important like you
know back in the day that was not always
the case and we have more
you know cultural like memory of like
these like
important people that accomplish great
things who are very smart who did great
things but like the average person got
and I think now like the you know the
people who have truly been like you know
forged in the fires of you know the
memetic internet you know are actually
extremely competent in a lot of these
things some of them I think most of it
it's like it's a selection process right
you know most people get caught you know
like you know you know bottom half or
bottom quarter gets caught into like Q
Anon or like whatever garbage then you
know you know lower half gets caught
into like you know Fox News versus CNN
or whatever you know you know you know
75th percentile gets caught into like
sophisticated Twitter arguments or
whatever you know 99 percentile gets
caught into like Niche politics whatever
first percentile actually smart or
whatever like actually is like extremely
sophisticated and can like actually like
be resistant to memes that you know
would have killed the Victorian child if
you think of a differences between now
and the past one of the most extreme one
is also the access to information so
this is kind of a
this is a point that that listeners and
everyone has heard a million times but
it's still important to consider just
how much information you're able to get
access to in any given day how much
information we've gone through how many
uh just in this in this podcast right
here uh how many Concepts we've we've
mentioned that you wouldn't hear about
if you lived say 200 years ago
yeah
um okay what what is the most impressive
scientific discovery relative to its
time when relative to when it was
discovered
well that's a nice question I like that
um
honestly I might go with Aristotelian
logic
and so there's a lot of problems with
Aristotelian lot and like Socratic and
like all this kind of stuff like there
is
like so much of his argument from
Authority and like so much of it's kind
of just like [__] ontologies kind of
pulled out of nowhere whatever but given
the time like damn like if you once
you're like really aware of how Savage
the world was back then and you but you
read like Socrates or like Aristotle or
like
other people at that time like you know
I know it's a it's such a meme to like
the ancient Greeks like it's such like
oh of course right such an you know
Western like you know like a lot of
people do fetishize ancient Greece and
like make it look as like much more than
it actually was but I think
actually appreciating that like like
inventing you know predicate or like
first sort of logic kind of just out of
nothing at that time is like actually
amazing I think in other worlds like if
Athens hadn't fallen and like had some
more so you know some other things had
gone differently I think the industrial
revolution could have happened in Athens
like I think they like they had steam
engines Bureau of Alexandria built a
steam engine like it like you know it
looks like the antitheaterian mechanism
and stuff like this like they were
actually extremely Advanced this is a
mechanical computer that was found in a
shipwreck that is a that is that looks
like something from the 17th century but
is actually more than 2000 years old
it's it's yeah it's insane like it's
like this is another thing that modern
people don't have a conception of but
like the idea of losing technology but
like going backwards is not something
that we're familiar with in our modern
world like we're we're only familiar
with progress but like in the ancient
world it was a very common idea that
there were Golden Ages or you know the
Miracles were possible and then those
ages ended and now Miracles aren't
possible anymore this is a very common
three themes throughout history and for
example after like the fall of Athens I
think there was like a there was such an
age and like also after the fall of Rome
there was ages where there's a lot of
Technology got lost you know Romans
could build things that later
civilizations could not build imagine
living in that Society imagine being
like a medieval peasant and you saw like
a Roman aqueduct like
it looks like out of Miracles like
another like fairy tale like you know no
one can build stuff like this perhaps
the thinking about Golden uh past golden
eras weren't actually it was true in a
sense back then yep I think I think so I
think we've inherited a lot of that and
it's no longer true like we are
currently in the greatest golden age to
ever live but it's but back in the day I
think it was very reasonable like if you
were a post-roman uh you know person and
you thought the Roman age as a golden
age I'm like yeah I think that's
actually quite reasonable the same thing
about the Athenians so yeah I would say
probably Everest alien logic or like
just like like actually not if I don't
know if it counts I don't know if this
counts but I would say like the general
pro to epistemology that came out around
like Athens and Alexandria around that
time there's like proto-scientific it
was so close so close like getting to
where the enlightenment got I think like
I think if all these if this would have
continued they could have like
discovered the scientific method they
were like so close a little bit more
empiricism a little bit more
falsification and they would have been
there yep I think literally that plus
just some more Economic Development just
like you know more population growth and
stuff like that and you know figuring
out like you know coal mining and stuff
and more efficiently like some more
Economic Development some more Social
Development like there is still like
it makes sense that Athens fell like you
know Athens was also very small actually
like they're only like 20 000 Athenians
plus like you know slaves and so on so
like there actually were that many of
them and which again is actually then
shocking that so few people had so many
of these like critical insights that
like or like you know it's like very far
Advanced compared to like almost
anywhere else in the world there were
other you know like Alexandria and stuff
was also very Advanced but like prepared
to like you know [__] like you know
Dramatics or whatever like you know they
were like still like barbarians The
Innovation per capita in Asian ancient
Athens uh must must perhaps the the
highest ever
yeah and I think this is a great example
of how the market is inefficient it's
like you can just like
most of computation like most of the
stuff Curry figured out or like
leipeness or whatever you can just
figure out by thinking like you like
there's some things where like you need
like it's like one of the reasons why
maybe uh you know Industrial Revolution
couldn't have happened in Athens but may
have been possible in the in the Roman
Empire is you need a certain amount of
scale you need a certain amount of
industrial capacity you need like
relatively good like steel working and
stuff like this to like build large
boilers and stuff you just like need
steel processing that's like quite
Advanced and like like Metallurgy and
like this is like the kind of stuff that
Romans were quite good at like roaming
concrete and like was like very like an
incredibly good building material they
had like quite Advanced Metallurgy and
stuff like this kind of stuff was like
super important to actually get to the
industrial Evolution it was not just
coming up with thermodynamics it was a
lot of it it was just like you know
incremental improvements and Metallurgy
and like you know smithing and like you
know the development of like building
materials and stuff like that which is
like something that like Athens I think
would struck they didn't have like very
good steel they they couldn't develop
like a lot of these things they could
maybe they could have developed it later
but that would require a lot more
industry so like if I had picked like
one other point where you know
civilization could have gone industrial
it would have been probably the Roman
Empire not Athens
um but
but yeah it's um
it shows how inefficient the market is
in that you can come up with like most
of modern mathematics with pen and paper
like you don't actually need like you
know Advanced steel or Advanced economic
economics or whatever like you put like
the fact that Aristotle exists is kind
of an existence proof that or like
euclip Euclid's may be an even better
example like you read Euclid's first
fifth you know elements and whatever and
you read it and you're like holy [__]
this is modern mathematics like this is
it has axioms it has postulates it like
you know he derives like sure it's like
not perfect and whatever but like holy
[__] like this was so far Advanced for
its time
and it was it was it remained Cutting
Edge up until around 1700 which is an
incredible achievement yeah maybe
useless elements is actually a better
than Aristotelian logic even maybe that
would be the my choice actually I I like
that choice okay
um are books outdated
I mean
yeah it's I mean now at this point
cultural and aesthetic which is like
fine like I like books as artifacts I
think they're nice
um I don't read books anymore as I have
back issues now so it's like sometimes
hard to find a good posed read-in
compared to just sitting in a nice
office chair in front of my screen
um but I mean the concept of writing is
definitely not outdated the
publishing that writing in books is
about it
yeah what's the replacement because if
you if you replace your book reading
with only podcasts or videos online then
you you lose some depth but if you go
all the way to only reading papers then
perhaps it it gets a bit uh
you you will consume less information I
sometimes joke that like you know
there's like a hierarchy of like a
quality of literature and like
non-fiction the lowest of the low is
like you know whatever your on posts on
Facebook you know that's like that's
like the bottom tier and then pick it up
and then you get like you know like a
bit above that it's like
mainstream kind of garbage you know it's
like very low quality whatever stuff and
it's like a lot of videos click bait
stuff and like whatnot then like one
step above that you have like you know
like pop style like books and like
magazines and stuff which is actually
not that bad you know there's some good
stuff on there but it's mostly still
garbage then
you get to like actual books you know
written by people who know what they're
talking about which is which has like
real information in them and is usually
accurate but it's usually outdated and
it's usually still like fluffy and like
you know more like partially for
entertainment and so on and then you get
to like you know like you know higher
level like papers like that's where like
you know actual scientific knowledge is
really shared and where it's actually
about the scientific knowledge that's
like where you need to be when you want
to like really catch up
and then in the ascended tier above that
is you know
un like poorly formatted WordPress blogs
by uh one obsessive artist with an anime
profile picture that is the truly
ascended form of the most high signal
writing ever created by mankind you know
guern is the epitome of human literature
as part of like non-fiction literature
as far as I'm concerned and there's like
a bunch of like these like Niche
guernesque you know
um blogs like some of them for like very
different like some from one topic some
for like all kinds of different topics
and many of them like absurdly well
researched and like I consider these
they're rare and like most like most
blogs are terrible but like there's
these like
um extremely Niche tail and like the
like the Tails of like blogs are much
longer than like any other medium
yeah I agree with that take it's uh I I
once considered uh only reading books
and not reading anything online for in
order to focus more but I just couldn't
take the loss of of these in-depth block
uh blog posts where it's it's it's
almost an insult to call it a Blog it's
more like a you know a research paper
but but more self-aware and highly
updated and yeah I yeah
is highly recommended definitely
absolutely so yeah I I don't really read
books anymore because I think the
Signal's too low like I think most books
actually the signal especially the
signal to like Words is actually quite
low in most books like
I read tons of books when I was younger
but it was more to like catch up on like
a common Corpus because like like the
common Corpus that like a lot of people
expect
people to know is in book form still so
like you know you should always like
everyone should read you know the
selfish Gene and like you know a few
books about history you should read um
you know read the sequences whatever you
know you know it's a bunch of stuff like
that that like you should have read but
then after that I mean the the current
place where the most you know absolute
Galaxy brain smartest Cutting Edge stuff
is posted is like mostly on blogs
do you think that uh language models
could become a could replace books
perhaps uh having a conversation with an
expert is one of the best ways to learn
and perhaps language models could become
so good that that they could teach you
uh better than say textbooks
I mean yeah obviously I mean given that
I think language models will lead to AGI
sooner or later then yeah obviously have
you done any of this have you so how do
you use these generative models in your
daily life if you do the funny thing is
I barely use them I'm like the uh like
there's a there's this meme this tweet
where it's like you know Tech Enthusiast
wow my entire home is smart I have
everything connected to my wife and it's
like Tech worker I I have one printer at
home and I keep a loaded handgun next to
it in case it makes a noise I don't
recognize
like I'm kind of like the second
category but is it actually a safety
issue that that Meme is about yeah I
mean it's not just a safety issue I mean
I am paranoid about like Online safety
and such to a large degree and such but
um
it is more just like don't trust
technology in many ways like I know it's
limits and its weaknesses I am very
interested in language models from like
a research perspective there's many
interesting things to do with them but
like for most of the work I need to do
um it's not particularly helpful like I
hit the limits very quickly like I'm
like I know what it can do and like I
hit those limits super quickly and
there's also
this is also why I have a good model of
like what they can and can't do and they
can't do a lot I could probably optimize
a lot if I put some effort into this
um but another one is actually safety is
that I the things I would want them to
do are not things I want open AI reading
my logs on you know I don't want to
share personally identifiable
information or by personal emails or
like whatever with openai I'm like yikes
like I don't want them building you know
like you know being able to train on my
interactions with you know people I
don't want them to be able to you know
if I had ways of improving their models
or like hitting their limits I wouldn't
want them to know about that necessarily
so there's also limitations there
um there is a lot of
there is a lot of useful things like I
probably should just use more like you
know there's a lot of like useful like
transcription stuff that also conjecture
has been working on some transcription
stuff which has been super super useful
really great tool if anyone to check it
out
um that we've been building there
um and stuff like that sometimes use AI
Generation stuff for my DND stories uh
like images but
um I use surprisingly little AI in my
day-to-day life one limit that I've come
across when I talk to language models is
just that it's you can't you can't
really go deep on a topic you know a lot
about but but then you then you if I'm
annoyed at at it's at GP at chat gbt's
inability to talk about some
philosophical issue that I'm interested
in then I have to remind myself that it
could actually Converse kind of uh
pretty pretty well with me on any given
topic to to to a certain level of depth
so and so it it knows much more than I
do about uh Plumbing uh theater and so
on any given topic but but I can see how
you
perhaps at this point it's difficult to
make progress in in your own knowledge
if you're already knowledgeable on topic
yeah it's like most of the knowledge I'm
interested in is on the level like word
and stuff yeah if like if I was
interested in you know something on like
a pop style level then I'm sure Chef GPT
would be helpful I just like genuinely
don't consume any Pop's eye like it's
just like not useful to me it's also not
very entertaining to me anymore I also
have the privilege of being surrounded
by very very many smart people that I
can just like talk to whenever I want
and so I expect if I would be more
isolated it would be more valuable but
like if I need to talk to an expert on
like programming language Theory I can
just get someone and just talk to them
so how close are we to having uh
personalized AI tutors for for children
for example based on language models are
we already there
I think you could have that I expect
children to be very very good at
immediately getting it to say bad words
uh it's definitely I would have done I
expect this not to happen why do we
expect not to happen regulation I expect
like I think so I'm one of those people
I think school is bad like obviously so
like it's like obvious it's child
torture like I consider school to be a
massive human rights violation like
absurdly so and if people if like our
descendants will look back at how we do
school nowadays and they'll be like you
did what to your kids you lock them in
these rooms with all these other
terrible kids and these like you know
mid-wit teachers that were like often
very abusive and like you know and no
one did anything about that well what
like excuse me
so like I expect this to be one of the
greatest moral atrocities of Earth not
the greatest but like this to be one of
the most pervasive moral atrocities of
our time that we torture our kids and
we're just like fine with it there's
another great example of how humans
don't really have morals like people are
like are not inherently good or evil
like they're just like they just go
along with whatever society says
um like if if school didn't exist and I
introduced the concept to you you would
be horrified you would never do this to
your kids you would be like I and the
teachers do what and how often is sexual
abuse what I'm not leaving them alone
with that with these like within the
scenarios
but because it's normal and everyone
does it like you get the [__] police
called on you if you don't want to go to
the torture chamber with all the other
kids to get tortured you know like this
is this is interesting since if you if
you ask uh I I think a lot of people
they would say that the kind of
education is something that everyone can
agree is is a good thing like family or
something like this but perhaps perhaps
you we should differentiate between
education and then the schooling the
school system as it looks now exactly so
this is the classic phenomena of where
so there's like the like classic Robin
Hansen you know elephant in the brain
another book everyone should read
um concept where something you know on
Surface optimizes for X everyone says
it's for X but in practice it obviously
is optimizing for y so like maybe
there's a different purpose and the
actual purpose of school is it is child
prison it's the kid the parents need to
go to work they need to do other things
they can't take care of the child they
don't want to spend that much time with
the child they have to like be put away
in the child prison and also you have to
civilize people children are feral like
you know children are animals like
obviously and like you know cute
adorable lovely animals and you know I
love kids uh but like
they are animals and like they if you
want them to integrate into society at
some point there has to be a civilizing
process the way this should work is you
know you have loving parents paying
close attention to them you know Stern
but loving father you know kind but
loving mother and loving mother whatever
but an industrial scale you know you
can't always guarantee that
so you know especially if you need
people and workers to be in a certain
kind of educational level you can't
guarantee that parents won't necessarily
do that you know it's in the modern
world you need to learn to read you need
to learn to you know do simple
mathematics and whatever and so
and most people do not want to learn
mathematics they really really don't and
you have to force them like you have to
literally use violence to teach people
math like some people that's not the
case like you know I think if you left
me as a kid just unsupervised in a room
I would have like you know just like
stumbled up on mathematics just because
I was bored and I thought it was fun it
was like puzzle like you know you left
me there with like a textbook and not
like I I would have probably just like
you know done it because I was bored but
for most kids that's not the case and if
you want kids to function in modern
society if you want them to be live as
fulfilling life and you know be able to
handle themselves you need to literally
use violence
like at scale again this is if you're a
dumb Society if you're a smart Society
oh do I have ways to solve this I have
lots of ways how we could solve this but
it requires an actual smart society
which we do not have to have a more
Humane schooling system where yeah
there's so many ways how we can make
school this wonderful experience that
like everyone backhand that helps people
grow as people you know become adults
you know like you know lots like fun
experiences where you know a real
challenged you get to like you know like
there's like yeah of course like that
does this have to do with Society simply
becoming richer and then thereby having
resources resources to become more
Humane become more perhaps uh
personalized in our approach to
education not uh putting every uh every
young person in the same box which is
yeah which were perhaps necessary in
some sense uh when the when the kind of
modern school systems were set up 200
150 years ago absolutely like a lot of
that like school is much better now than
it was before obviously like you know as
much as I you know am being direct here
that school is torture and I do consider
it Torture
um and like it is like obviously so and
it's like so much better than it used to
be like obviously like especially at
least in you know which like you know a
lot of people do have fond memories from
school I have some fun man from school
even so I guess they're mostly torture
you know still there's a lot of nice
things so my teachers were really nice
and they taught me some great things and
I'm happy that I got to spend time with
them and I had some good friends there's
also a lot of really traumatic
experiences as every kid has during
those times and
it's um it's cruel gas lighting this is
like why I'm like passionate about this
it's like very crucial gaslighting that
like you know kids are put into these
terrible situations where they like
being bullied or like the teachers are
cruel or abusive and they or they're
like you know they're either been ADHD
and they just like can't pay attention
and they're like forced to sit still and
like it's like genuinely painful like
you know as a kid with ADHD like this
was like genuinely just like very very
terrible and I got you know lots of [__]
for that and I only got away with it
because I was like pretty smart but like
you know if I was not been smart and I
would have like failed in school this
would have been like absolutely
traumatic it's a bit horrible I was like
no I did get into trouble a lot because
I just not pay attention I'd be like you
know wiggling and like you know talking
and such but I got lucky and
if but it's still better like you know
right like you know no one hit me you
know in school I was never abused I was
never hurt like you know I was yelled it
you know sometimes but like you know no
one ever hurt me that was not the case a
while ago you know I was born like 30 50
years ago yeah but she was gonna beat
the [__] out of me like obviously so
um maybe rightfully but you know
um no it's I'm joking obviously yeah but
the problem is
I think is it's not just money it's also
money it's also money and stuff but it's
like
uh then this is man I'm so cynical today
oh it's just so sad but like
the core problem is much worse than that
like that one of the core problems of
civilization of humanity that comes up
again and again in different guises is
this problem that like
just most people aren't that great like
man like just like most adults are just
like they also have their [__] you know
they're also kind of immature they're
like you know they don't they don't give
good advice and they're like they can
get angry and like whatever and like as
a kid you're in a particularly
vulnerable state it's actually basically
the same relationship like the same type
of relationship that exists between like
a patient and a therapist so there's
this current movement kind of going on
where like everyone's to go to therapy
everyone should have a therapist I'm
like whoa slow the [__] down there uh
I'm not sure that's a good idea
um I think the idea of therapy is great
the idea of having you know someone
guide you through emotional issues help
you grow as a person someone to talk
you're like oh wonderful yeah fantastic
now let's look under the rug and see how
this actually works oh no and like
school is the same kind of issue we're
like oh education you're teaching kids
how to be adults and how to do useful
things wow this is so wonderful let's
look how oh no
so that's I consider these the same
class of problems where like if you have
a great therapist who's intelligent and
sure and they care and they're like like
wow that's like that's such a high value
experience same thing with the teacher
we have a great teacher smart kind
patient and really believes in you and
helping you that's a wonderful
experience that's like such as like as a
kid having a mentor you know having a
some adults that are really looking out
for you they're rooting for you is so
important you know both your your
teachers about and your parents and so
you really have your parents and they're
behind you you know they're rooting for
you that's so important as a kid it's so
valuable but you just can't guarantee
that at scale man most teachers are just
dudes you know they're just like some
kind of people they're just like oh they
don't want to be here either they don't
even like kids like [__] what is um what
is the belief or an opinion you have
that is very different from those of
your in-group
hmm
well depends on how in the in group is
um
um I have various spicy opinions about
like you know
coordination politics and what we
already mentioned some of this
if I
I guess if you used to find my
in-group as like not like literally my
friends but like you know wider cultural
context probably my like belief in like
um you know like virtue and like these
kind of Concepts or more like um
well here's a fun answer let me give you
okay instead of give you a serious
answer how about give you a fine answer
instead okay fun answer is
um
whole schizo Theory
about basically how like all of like
um religion mythology spirituality and
stuff are like actually really important
and like completely mechanistically
understandable like I think that like
um if you replace the word spiritual
with like a virtual if you replace like
magic with or like spells with memes
it just works you have a congrats you
have a mechanistic understanding of
magic so like I think that there are
that like concept of magic is very real
and like you know like you know actually
with a K kind of is like very real and
like actually a very meaningful concept
but it's just it's very confused like
people are confused about I think it's
like a physical concept it's not like
magic is to reality as computation is
the CPUs
or like computer programs are to CPUs so
like one of my favorite examples of this
is is that
um there are many try there's many
groups like yeah that and especially
southeast Asia which have a myth about
the evil eye so the way this works is
the shaman can put or the sorcerer or
whatever can put in certain type of
curse called an evil eye on a person and
then they will like wither and die if
they get the Eli so this is true this
has been this is observable is that
people who get the I grow like thick and
they often die this is real this is
observable empirically observable
phenomena now how do you explain this
well you know if you try to explain this
with like you know a purely you know
like physicalist driven you know like
just like view you're like that doesn't
make any sense this can't be possible
but like surely there's like some
mistake here well no I think there's
another aspect if you look at this
medically there's a very simple
explanation for this the simple the
explanation is very simple
when the shaman cast the evil eye
they make a common knowledge that the
evil eye is on this person the tribe now
all know oh [__] this guy's got the evil
eye on him [__] I don't want I don't
want to talk to him so he just gets
neglected that's it everyone he it's a
it's a softer attack
the shaman performed a software attack
on the operating system running on the
general medic environment they
introduced a meme into the environment a
toxic meme which was directing a
specific person which changed the like
predictably so changed the minds of the
other people to start neglecting this
person and by neglect people die and
people get sick but this uh this kind of
this reinterpretation of magic in terms
of memes and signaling and Social
Psychology is still perfectly compatible
with a physicalist uh world yes it's
just it's just a a slightly weird way of
thinking uh about it yes exactly it's
it's I was naive physicalist would have
been the correct way to say that it's
like I think magic is as real as a
Python program on your computer it's
like you know what does the program
exist
debatable like you can say it's encoded
in physical states of course and it has
physical con you know
consequences on reality none of this is
like unique to me like these are
obviously things that other people have
noticed as well
um you know like even like all the way
back like your structured interpretation
of computer programs opens with this
like nice chapter like a nice little
intro where he's like you know oh we
have Sorcerers encoding you know Arcane
glyphs onto magic stones that summons in
material spirits that can have effects
on reality and that's you know what we
call a computer program and programming
on a CPU a computer program like you
know so I saw this talk about you know
that I've mentioned this before like the
idea of like the missing science of the
Medics I think the missing science
memetics is also missing science magic
and it's like when I say Medics I mean
like a science that can predict how
memes would be effective in the given
environment like we should have an
ontology a way of thinking about how to
cast spells like how can we like uh I
it's a bit of a dark one but I have a
really good example for this it's a bit
dark
um but so
there is a truly terrible thing that has
that happened a lot in over the last you
know 10 20 years which is school
shootings this is a truly truly tragic
thing this is a terrible thing no one
wants this to happen everyone wants to
prevent this
but somehow they keep happening somehow
this keeps happening especially in the
US well what causes this well you know
one obvious explanation is guns that's a
pretty that's pretty reasonable Theory
but then we look at like Canada or like
Switzerland or whatever and they have as
many guns as America and sometimes more
and they don't have this problem or it's
like much much much much rarer like
orders magnitude and like okay so you
know maybe it's definitely contributing
to the problem but like is it the
problem well not really well having more
guns obviously also doesn't solve it
like I don't think I need to prove that
like obviously it doesn't help so not
that what is it why does it happen in
America but not in Switzerland that's
kind of weird so there's a lot of weird
explanations for well you can you can
have for this you know you can you know
economic disparity or like mental health
treatment or whatever but I think
there's a much more sobering
much more sobering reality is its memes
it's cool to do it's just because of the
way the media treats School shooters in
the US it has become the default script
the Fate the you know encoded in our
cultural mythology as a school shooter
as these like evil boogie man like this
is the thing that evil people do this is
the if you spread off the path of light
into the path of pure Darkness this is
what happens so what has happened is is
that a
deviously toxic meme has embedded itself
into the cultural reality of the of
especially the United States and the
Anglo-Saxon world and you know the
English-speaking World in general like
these things don't really happen like in
Asia they're like much much there
because it's a different cultural
context it's a different spiritual realm
so to speak so
what do you do so okay what is my
solution how do we stop school shootings
the truth is we have to make it uncool
the what I think what actually has to be
done is you need to have a anti-meme you
have to like release memes you have to
change the spiritual story
around this about evil good and so on to
make it not the thing that evil people
want to do you have to give them
something else to do because they will
always be evil people there always be
people who feel betrayed who want to
like take vengeance upon Society or
whatever and basically you have to cast
a spell you have to manipulate them into
thinking that they should do something
different and I have no idea how the
hell to do this like holy [__] like you
know like if like if I was a advanced
civilization with an advanced science
with my Medics I should be able to solve
this like an alien comes from space
looks at us like ah yes this is a Class
2 a b memetic Hazard I know what to do
let's let's activate protocol D and then
they'd like do something and like say
some words and things will be solved do
you think that do you think that we
could actually get a science of mimetics
uh going because you know the sciences
that have been very successful are
scientists that are not in that are
studying something where where humans do
not interact with the object physics uh
chemistry the biology to some extent but
the one perhaps one reason why sociology
and economics aren't that successful uh
it's because you're studying something
where where humans are interacting with
the system and with mimetics you're
studying you're basically what you're
studying is is purely humans interacting
with each other and so wouldn't it be
too fast moving and fragile and complex
for for you for us to pin down say you
know uh Newtonian laws of mimetics
oh yeah absolutely there will not be
Newtonian laws for this this is a level
two science like I think humans have
like mastered level one science pretty
well you know like look up how like an
euv lithography machine works like what
the [__] how the hell do humans build
that so the fact that we can build that
I'm like okay yeah we we understand like
level one like physical science cool if
you look at the things that are actually
hard for modern science like the things
we actually just like cannot do you
always get back to complexity and
interactivity you get back to you know
you know hard algorithmic problems
biology sociology economics all these
kind of things like what do these things
have in common well multiple things one
thing is reactivity and like chaos and
how by interacting like level two chaos
in the sense that you interacting with
the system makes it chaotic so
this like this is the interesting
version of the efficient market
hypothesis you fit the interesting
version is that is a system which is
chaotic by you interacting if it is not
chaotic you interacting with it will
make it chaotic from your perspective
this is a very interesting property to
have this is like an adversarial
property the market is adversarial this
is also interesting from the perspective
AI this is why Ai and AGI is
fundamentally different from other kinds
of like disaster or like you know risk
management because you're dealing with
an adversarial system when you're
dealing with like volcanoes or like you
know viruses or whatever like viruses
are kind of an intermediate stable same
volcanoes they're not malicious like the
volcanoes are maximizing their damage to
college to human they're not like once
they it's not like once you learn where
the volcano is the volcano goes
somewhere else to hide from you right
it's just like you know the level one
problem it's like you know okay there's
a physical phenomena out there in
reality it might be complicated it might
be you know like you know we might need
to develops a new Theory or whatever
it's a new measuring devices but like
you know humans are actually pretty
decent at that not great but really
pretty decent at this level two problems
are different level two problems are
things that evolve to react that fight
and this is to a large degree like
exactly why these designs so hard like
sociology is harder than physics
obviously like now physics studies you
know like physics is the science of the
first order Taylor derivative uh an
expansion right and sociology is much
much more confident this is why
sociology is terrible you know like if
you read an average sociology you know
like paper horrible terrible terrible
terrible like no signal and
um and I think the reason is not you
know necessarily lack of trying it's
just that this is really really hard and
it's developed it requires the
development of like science too you know
like scientific method 2.0 to be able to
like deal with these kinds of scenarios
I think we've seen some early
developments words like scientific
method 2.0 and we have some
methodologies that are like much more
advanced and like anything like proper
or such would think about like poppers
like you know classic like science 1.0
kind of stuff while like modern
conceptions of science are much more
complicated and involve other ways of
gaining information about reality and
such but as an existence proof
about how I think this is hard but not
impossible uh consider that the shaman
can cast the evil eye
how did you do that well he understood
he had a Model A causal model of how
things around him work and how if you do
if he says certain spells and he like
you know frantically waves his hands or
whatever that he can then
accomplish a intera intervention in
reality there's an intervention be why
you know that maybe maybe it's passed
down from shame and Shaman but like some
someone figures out that they could do
this and that it worked and then they
kept it around so
it's if if that like proto-scientific
view can already understand quite a lot
of things like actually humans very
naturally have a lot of sense for these
kinds of things like how to be
convincing how to be you know like a an
in tune sense for social reality
and if anything most people for most
people social reality is more natural
than actual reality
like actual reality is actually quite
unnatural for most people most people
don't really interact with physical
reality they interact
through social reality and most people
when they the fundamental ontology that
most people think in is not atoms and
bits and whatever it's like people and
alliances and friends and family and
stuff like that which are you know
fundamentally high level of Concepts so
I think
we're at the stage of like
there's lots of low-hanging fruit it's
very hard if I had like tons of time you
know and AGI wasn't around the corner
maybe I would work on the signs of
memetics you know as things my brain you
know takes a liking to these kinds of
thoughts so maybe I'll be working on
that
a formal theory of magic
we have a we have a better intuitive
grasp of social dynamics than we do
about physics for example but why is the
why is our uh scientific theories of
physics then more advanced than our
scientific theories of mimetics if if
our if we start out with a uh
you know if we start with a better
starting point in the social realm why
can't we make faster progress there
because physics is just easier like much
easier and it's not adversarial so this
is like the memetic evolution thing is
that by the it's like
if I had to do if I was sent back 2 000
years whatever or whatever I spoke the
language I could like memetically
destroy these people like I could make
them laugh I could make them you know
believe anything I say I could out argue
Socrates easily if circuit just came up
to me I would destroy him not because
I'm smarter than him circuit test was
probably much smarter than me but
because I have been like I've heard all
his arguments I've I am so medically you
know I know I grew up on you know
[__] the internet like I've I have
debated and argued like man I would
destroy Socrates he would be like like
he he would just rage quit if he had to
debate me like and not just me to be
clear there's like lots of people that
like you know in modern reality like
most most like high school Debaters I
think destroys okra with us
so but so it's an evolution the problem
gets harder as you interact with it
if you were to choose one person or
group in history that has helped
Humanity the most by your values uh what
personal group would you choose
um
question
not sure I can
like pick out
anyone in particular like think about
counter factual impact
won't be the highest kind of factual
impact like there's lots of people who
did great things you know like you know
creating vaccines or like developing
like you know various branches of
science but a lot of them I think are
not counter factually that important
like I think a lot of these science
would have been developed anyways you
know Turing hadn't existed I think like
you know Conrad Zuzu would have like you
know invented things you know if
Einstein hadn't existed then um Lorenz I
think it was would have like invented
special relativity
um so what we're thinking about is
perhaps a bit like the question about
Aristotle or Euclid where yeah we think
about who made who made the the earliest
progress on a difficult problem but in
in the ethical realm yeah yeah so I'm
thinking I mean
yeah like someone who was ahead of his
time was Jeremy Bentham but I'm not sure
how big his influence was like I know if
he would be like the person who's made
the the most differentiable impact I
mean you could also give the the you
know like MiMi answers of you know like
standard of Petrov and stuff like the
people who inverted nuclear war
um I expect whoever actually did the
most good is someone that history has
forgotten just like some person in some
scenario just to made a choice
that really made the world a better
place and were never celebrated from it
but I don't have a clever answer for
this one
perfect is AI generated content the
future of media obviously
like I I've gone on the record to say in
the past that I expect you can generate
full like Hollywood movies
in like the next couple years I expect
that's possible
both full Hollywood movies in the next
couple of years yeah that would that
would surprise me but yeah I've been
surprised many times so perhaps I
haven't updated all the way as as you
mentioned before yeah just update all
the way bro
all right perfect let's end it there
then this uh this has been fantastically
interesting to me Connor I hope I hope
it's been interesting to you too yeah I
had a great time thanks so much for
having me perfect